[Music]
this is ogoniland in southeastern
nigeria
an area which over the years has been
devastated by toxic oil spills
fishermen and farmers complained that
the spills have ruined their health
the local environment as well as their
livelihoods
they say international oil companies are
to blame
the european parliament wants new rules
to make sure that tragedies like this
don't happen in the future that means
that workers will be better protected
and if not that victims will have better
access to remedy
and better access to justice and
companies can be held liable
if they don't respect human rights the
new rules would not only apply to
companies based in the eu
but any company seeking to trade in the
eu's internal market
they would all have to prove their
supply chains were from start
to finish free from human rights
violations
and didn't harm the environment today
only
one in three eu companies is taking due
diligence measures
so that's not enough the consequence is
that we have headlines like
run a plaza or pollution in nigeria and
that means that we now need to go a step
further
victims could seek redress in eu courts
and companies would face fines if they
harmed people
the planet or good governance parliament
wants the rules
to go even further traditionally trade
agreements have protected investors more
than
the workers in the supply chain it's
important that
we introduce these new rules before we
enter into new trade agreements
the legislation should also allow the eu
to ban any imports linked to human
rights violations like forced
or child labour